oh god don't touch me please
[Music]
how's it going bro
dude i'm recording this on my laptop
listen to this
it's gonna explode i hope i can make it
through this
we're playing
poppy playtime
yeah
i am definitely the first one to have
ever played this game no one has uh
feels good i just found this before i
just found it on my own but yeah it
looks it looks pretty cool here we go
welcome thanks
you can pause in this game i always
appreciate that
we gotta we gotta oh
oh no i already broke game
computer i love you petey oh computer
you love me whoa what the [ __ ]
wait don't push me
yeah that's right [ __ ]
oh perfect let's put it in here
hi
my name is late pierre and i'm the head
of innovation here at the playtime code
georgia i feel like i'm too short for
this then you're trespassing
yeah hey please whenever we close the
factory for the day
we're going to beat the game together
computer don't worry about it
don't worry about it it's not too late
to turn around
for sure
right
computer maybe it'd be leaks
we're going to beat the game to get a
main i'll leave marzia for your computer
and that's a promise
interact
oh i got it
a computer
there
i got it i got it whoa
did you see that
it was amazing all right green
purple purple purple okay got it
computer
yes the physics in this game is perfect
i love hey
fling and play football
i love it i think i broke oh god i mean
that so now i don't know it was green
[Music]
yeah
big memory let's go
so smart and then you're so smart thank
you computer
you're smart too man you're like
literally a computer
computer
oh god more videos okay here we go
let's check it out
computer you gotta watch
there we go oh cool so i get the thing
now i've seen this
computer please pay attention tighten
the straps okay called above cannons
don't mind if i do
okay
oh i can bring you with me computer
yes absolutely
do not fire it
got it
you're welcome
all right
so far this is pretty great do i get it
or
give me
oh here we go
the game looks good i got i gotta say
computer
i can touch you now
hooray
this is great news all right
yeah no no no all right
we're gonna beat we're gonna beat game
together
and stuff
there you go
[Music]
oh sit
look at that computer look at him look
at what i did
oh
[Music]
let's go a computer
don't get jealous but uh
hey computer
don't be jealous about uh
but uh
oh you can't do it are you kidding me
there it is
don't demonetize please
[Music]
my god damn it computer
why you gotta do like that oh
well i don't mind if i do
staff only
uh i'll be right back computer i'll be
right back
yo they got brooms in this game that's
awesome
i need to stop what am i doing
we got some
jesus
calm down dude ah oh
oh
[Music]
oh oh it's like tesla coils
god they're so loud dude
what are they
hello
computer
no
no no no why why why
why why cool
oh this is bad
come back to me
curse you game curse you
you will pay for this
[ __ ] you smuggy
yeah
i'm not afraid and i will not be friends
with you nice hairy legs
hello
flinch do not open my pores with steam
without my consent game
you can't do it
have you seen computer
excuse me have you seen
such a strange gameplay but i kind of
like it
it's kind of
cool remember to take breaks all right i
will oh
okay
can i oh
does that go there where's the amazon
delivery package uh factory
oh there's another one
oh
get out of the way
gibby skippy
yeah
oh we're back here okay
that's another one
oh look it's smart secretion factory wow
computer
you've kidnapped computing telling me
how it is
whoa
no that's creepy stop it i didn't think
i could touch it
can i build the baby
oh little child
little child
oh baby child moves
oh
i want to make a baby
no all right i'm not doing it actually
i'm bored
okay
oh it is blue i thought it was white
there we go
yeah
old school horror gameplay hey you
remember when i was doing that
get it it ain't no oh god damn it ain't
no computer
but it is uh thanos club i don't know
oh
let's go race the route
now i'll find computer for sure
for sure bro
is that eyeball
don't care only one computer love
forever
now i'm too tall dude oh
there we go
[Music]
so far very cool game but not very scary
game have to say
where i go i walk in circles oh never
mind i did something
what
how is that not it mate
oh oh oh
oh oh
i'm dumb
i'm bummy rooney smoony
let's go
no
all right
i like it
[Applause]
all right
oh hello have you seen computer
leg
oh
whoa what just happened don't break the
game felix please nobody leaves without
a toy okay
i'll just bring my computer
and i'll be on my merry way thank you
very much
it's cool uh cool music too i like it
wait a minute wait a minute
no no no
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
is it touching
[Music]
i think i'll jump down
that would have hurt if i had legs which
i don't let's go
okay
did i click on it that's right click
that was too loud man
hey
what the hell is that oh oh i'm making
those okay
i wish i made a computer but you will
have to do
like
i see you on the other side like
it's very detailed detail game i like it
not scary though i'm not scared so far
oh god
what did i do
make a friend it reminds me build-a-bear
we have in uk i don't know if you have
that in other countries it's pretty much
the same
thing hey you turned out so good
wow
pretty sh toy i would rather have a
computer but you know
i take what i can get come to poppy
yeah
here you go all right now we're going to
leave
i broke the game oh
oh damn it okay nobody leads to that toy
oh perfect nice
excellent
[Music]
i'm sorry bro i'm sorry we can work this
out we can work this out
stop
oh
what is happening what's happening
oh god why did i get zero to 100 man
it's fine it's fine don't hurt me
because sweetness remember
[Music]
oh god don't touch me please
we're good
oh my god oh my god one now
one now
i can't go
sexy evan
all right
okay i kind of get why this game is
popular now i get it gamers i'm a gamer
too do i have to do all that again
ah
bro
brother oh he's not gonna he's not gonna
do it
i i know that i know the way now i'm not
even scared anymore
[ __ ] me this sucks
[Music]
oh oh my god pull it pull it
that was dope
it's been a while since i got spooked
that was genuinely spoopy
this doesn't look like a factory to me
i don't know about you guys
oh there's a hidden door here
at the very end
computer behind it all i knew it that
was computer all along
you opened my case
a tight
squeeze that was pretty dope i like that
well done well done
i'm impressed
i thought it was cool i think this is
chapter one maybe yeah yeah yeah so
there will be more
if you want part two
smash like subscribe that's all you
gotta do and i'll see you then thanks
for watching
breakfast